hi there you know we're gonna have
today's gonna be a boring me in front of
the computer camera event my wife Carmen
is quite creative in using my iPhone too
you know like I thought yesterday that
maybe she started videoing me sweeping
the floor and then gradually covered the
rest of the kitchen was kind of well
done so we're gonna do more of those and
I'm gonna do more of these selfie type
deals to make it more interesting for
you but today I was just too busy so
here I am at the end of the day but are
we now 10 o'clock and evening it's just
me today
27 we're almost at 30 we're almost 1/3
of the way in some ways I feel as if I
haven't really achieved much in 27 days
I've been at it and yet on the other
hand I just had a conversation at 8:30
with one of my tutors and there's no
question I was more comfortable and so
you know we can't be paid we can't be
impatient and I think my theme today is
patience language learning is about
patience you have to be patient and so
often I see people that are so impatient
you know I don't understand this and
they're almost mad at the language
because the language has structures that
are confusing to us that seemed to us
illogical that don't make sense
according to the logic of our own
language why do they say that they've
got extra words in there they've got you
know that doesn't make sense and all of
these kind of impatient reactions to the
language which is so you know
counterproductive it will what you've
got initially with a foreign language is
something that is foreign it is foreign
it is not familiar it is strange it is
not close to you it's not your friend
it's but it's not your enemy either and
what I find with my Korean now as I
listen to more and more of it it's
starting to become my friend as I spark
speak to my Korean tutor it's it's
becoming my language slowly he's it's
less of a foreign language out there and
it's slowly becoming my language and
that
the process you gradually become
familiar with the language you get used
to the language your brain gets used to
some of the patterns that takes time we
have to be patient we can't expect it
like now and why isn't this like that or
you know sometimes I don't know you look
up a meaning in the dictionary for a
word and it doesn't correspond to the
context so you get mad can't get mad at
the dictionary things that seem strange
to you now will eventually seem normal
and natural as the language becomes more
natural to you and it's a gradual
process so patience is very important
and I guess that's the main theme today
patience and of course because I've
given myself this 90 day challenge I
want to achieve some absolutely you know
measurable or significant results but
normally I wouldn't put this kind of
pressure on myself it's a promotion it's
good I think intensity is good as long
as we don't have expectations that we're
gonna hit bingo at the end of it we will
do better because we're more intense but
we still want to enjoy it and I accept
the fact that it's a gradual process
insofar as my own learning today I spend
a little more time with ICML but in the
end you know I CML is slower it's easier
I can understand it there's a few words
that I miss every time the same places I
can go back and try and nail those few
words down but I think there's a sort of
a diminishing returns situation there so
what I'm now doing is I'm gonna work
with this course that one of our members
Imani has put in that comes from Radio
Free Asia that is called sang sang Chong
J like lively economics or whatever they
spoken in a very natural casual but at a
high tempo and I remember when I started
studying Chinese and they have this
thing called Chinese dialogues and it
seemed to me that they were speaking so
quickly that they were doing this
deliberately to make it difficult for us
to understand like why are they speaking
so quickly but eventually I got used to
that temple so similarly here it's
spoken quite quickly there's a lot of
words and I'm sorry gonna stay with this
until I can understand it
every time I study the language there
have been a few sort of pivotable
pivotal texts that seemed very difficult
at first and spoken quite quickly and if
I was able to stay with those and master
those that kind of springboarded me into
another level so I've got to get now
with these texts about economics sort of
dialogues this is normal content for
Korean people if I can get to where I
understand these I believe it's gonna
catapult me forward and I'm quite
prepared to struggle with it for a week
for two weeks I'm prepared to be patient
so today all I'm gonna say is in your
language learning learn to be